Helpsters, our goal is to help Heart
prepare to play tee-ball now.
Who's got an idea?
Oh, me, yeah.
If we're playing tee-ball, we need a ball.
I have a ball.
Oh.
Great, OK.
So that's done.
And I know how to catch but I do not have a glove.
Well, then we will fix that with job one.
Get a tee-ball glove.
In tee-ball, you have to hit a ball with a bat.
I have a bat but I do not know how to hit.
Oh, then we shall teach you.
We certainly shall, and that is job two.
Teach Heart how to hit the tee ball.
OK, OK.
Oh, you see, Heart, yeah, you see that door over there open?
Yeah, would you mind closing that please?
I will do this.
OK.
OK, come to a huddle.
Oh, OK.
Yeah, yeah.
What's all this then?
Well, Heart seems a little nervous about playing tee-ball,
am I right?
Yeah, I noticed that.
Yeah, so what I was thinking is maybe
we should surprise Heart at the game
to show how much we believe in Heart.
A surprise job?
Yeah.
What a wonderful idea.
Thanks.
Great.
But I'm not going to put it on the board, OK?
Because it's a surprise.
Exactly, buddy.
OK, break, break.
I closed the door.
That is fantastic Heart, and guess what?
We have our plan.
We've got the plan, got the plan.
We've figured it out.
We've got the plan.
What happens when we've got the plan?
We give a happy shout just because we can.
Woo-hoo!
I'll go find a place to practice.
Great.
And I'll get to work on the secret job.
And Heart, you and I will go get a glove
by visiting glove store Glen.
Cody, Heart, wonderful to see you both.
What kind of glove can I get for you?
A tee-ball glove.
Mm-hmm.
I have several.
Let me show you.
Over here.
Oh, hello.
Which glove is the glove for me?
Well, let's make a rule to help us choose.
If the glove fits on your hand, then it's the glove for you.
How about this one?
No, too small.
Then it is not the glove for you.
Last one.
Oh, it fits!
Get a tee-ball glove, check.
Thanks so much Glen!
Thank you.
Good-bye Glen.
Heart, I have set up the tee-ball tee just for you.
I do not know what to do now.
Oh, well, why don't we go through the sequence, huh?
Yes, please.
Take it away Scatter.
OK.
First, put both hands on the bat.
Next, swing the bat away from the ball.
Last, swing the bat towards the ball.
Mm.
I did not hit it.
Hmm.
I wonder if there's something wrong with the sequence.
Well, let's go through it slowly, OK?
OK.
First, put both hands on the bat.
OK, looking good.
Next, swing the bat away from the ball.
Heart, you're not looking at the ball.
After you swing the bat away from the ball--
Then look at the ball.
Mm.
Last, swing the bat toward the ball.
Mm-hmm.
I hit the ball!
Yeah, you did!
Teach Heart how to hit a tee ball, check.
Let's get you to the game.
Hooray!
Yeah!
Great news, Toni.
We have your tee-ball player.
Na-na!
It is me.
Great news everybody.
We have enough players to play.
Oh, wonderful.
Yeah, Heart's on the team.
Looks like you're first.
First?
Yeah.
Here's your bat.
Thank you.
You got this Heart.
We're going to go find some seats, OK?
Yeah!
Where is Mr. Primm with the secret job?
Right here.
Oh, great.
Hey, Heart?
Hm?
Helpsters heart Heart.
That means that they love me!
Surprise Heart at the game, check.
Thank you, my friends.
We believe in you!
Remember the sequence!
First, put both hands on the bat.
Next, swing the bat away from the ball.
Then look at the ball.
Last, swing the bat towards the ball.
Yeah!
Hooray!
Run around the bases Heart!
[CLAPPING]
You're doing great, Heart.
Oh, Heart, there's nobody--
Yes, yes!
Woo!
Come on, Heart.
You got this, you got this.
Yes, you're almost home!
Heart!
Woo!
Yes!
Yes.
I did it.
I made a point.
Yeah!
Hooray!